Donald Trump do you think a businessman
like Trump has a chance to be president
do you think he has any shot at all do
you think this is real um no just
because no one would work with them like
Republicans and Democrats would be
babies and they would pout because
they're like bought and owned and it's
like how come this guy's free right and
gets to say whatever he wants I mean I
don't know I've enjoyed the hell out of
them just all the stuff the guy's been
saying I just I hope more politicians
are just at least just saying what
they're thinking right I love when they
were going like yeah you you said all
this sex of stuff about women you said
this about women you said that about
women you said this and he goes I said
that about Rosie O'Donnell no no you
said it about other women too when he
goes yeah you probably right that's all
you're gonna do is just amazed what I do
you know I it wants while I have a
couple shots of bourbon that go off on
the Broads and you know I get down to
business
any night so it is crazy like so many
people spend all their time in the media
apologizing and explaining and he just
if people that just say yeah that's what
I did they seem to get away with it yeah
that's what you do
I think comics should do that when
people get like annoyed and they go into
your Twitter account from 10 years ago
mm-hmm and they go you you said this
about you know whatever it's Saved by
the Bell in 1988
I want an apology that's like I won't
get in a time machine and talk to me
back then yeah you do you think
politicians should let their human side
come out yeah absolutely
I absolutely oh by me I don't think it
matters who's president I'm one of those
people doesn't doesn't doesn't matter it
all Hillary Clinton goes to those
Bilderberg meetings that's like the
Illuminati stuff right she probably
hooked up with some guy wearing like a
goat's head and then she goes out on TV
and she's talking to people who drive
snowplows like she can relate to him
I like Republicans better than Democrats
because they just say I know they don't
like me I know that they don't want me
in their neighborhood they're pushing
people wheelchairs down the stairs I
made this for me you beat it so they're
being honest you think no I mean I don't
think any of them aren't it's like look
I'll say this though like just the stuff
that they focus on you know me there's a
guy from Nestle that doesn't think water
is a human right I mean that guy should
be hunt down and shot right and they're
gonna sit and just talk about talking
about all the up I know what they're
talking about you know we gotta get
America back to work I go it's like dude
this guy wants to own the rain knows it
Nestle you're supposed to be happy let's
make it
cocoa for people this guy's like oh well
people are running out of water what if
we owned all the water and we kept it
under our place and in the future and
everybody that's how you picture the guy
talked out on the water come to the door
in a robe slightly ajar hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography